a gente ia conversar é porque eu sou um
táxi com dinheiro mas apesar de ser um
péssimo cozinheiro protótipo cozinhar
para falar a minha vantagem é que existe
uma coisa chamada internet e tentar
alguma coisa vai ser captado a
propaganda chamada tudo gostoso como eu
não poderia ficar sem contabilidades
facilmente é muito gostoso
com alguns cliques igual com a ser feito
para que eu e os ingredientes enquanto
passar uma situação fácil garante também
ser hoje estou me sentindo muito bem
isso é muito legal mas a verdade é que
outros quatro programas muito simples
ele é simples primeiro
os recursos a minha situação ele é
simples porque eu tenho as variáveis
conhecidas e eu tenho uma receita de
passar próximo a convidar pra cima dela
e ainda mais ricas porque aí a gente
está junto com o primeiro então você
nunca mais difícil de fazer o cliente
mas quem sabe o que o governo vem
trabalhando muito mais evidente gente
conversa mas por enquanto é um problema
simples montar outra curiosidade que tem
a ver com um problema muito complexas ou
não vão falar que o nosso sistema
educacional de brasileiros com políticas
fundamental têm habilidades adequados
isso a gente ainda tava métrica da
educação século 21
a provocação do atacante e começa a
falar sobre ele
competitivas começa a falar de
apresentações promocionais como é só
falar tinha habilitação para o exercício
da cidadania
aí realmente as mãos ainda em tempo você
trabalha é incorporada à educação como a
educação
eu fiquei 11 cálculo é época de fazer
uma educação diferente vou buscar
referências no brasil a fora porque
ainda sou diferente
aconteça o que acontecer e de pessoas
que estão vendo hackear o sistema do
kers e tentando afundar e especialmente
em toca à educação política de educação
cidadã que nós não temos como o que
vivemos o qual é necessário e urgente e
eu encontrei gente fosse uma viagem que
jogava uma experiência mudança time nem
deu para a promoção da madeira que a
oposição democrática mas sendo uma
professora de matemática mundo a
internada há necessidade de politizar os
11 de engajados nas causas
a unidade ainda não começou o projeto
chamado robson que ele tem até aqueles
alunos né da escola pudesse ter uma
oportunidade
por meio de uma metodologia pela costa
acontecia já identificar e resolver
problemas na escola comunidade e se não
conseguissem de todos os programas
oportunidade pudessem ricardo para
aquele que merece receber e criará a
prefeitura me que não é mais a
metodologia está longe eles elevem seus
prefeitos e esse efeito porque pretende
atingir toda a comunidade que a casa é
uma pessoa ela conversou com esse
projeto é essa a pretensão de se viajar
ele é repetente matemática do brasil de
preferência
ele era um deles está como muitos
adolescentes no japão que não via
nenhuma perspectiva de futuro estamos a
preparar uma escola estadual recebendo
essa aplicação em produtos
esse sistema
muito mais do que aquele que acredita
que o time gaúcho na fase final
estudar praticar assaltos e maurício
fazer porque esse ano é pretendido
automático não estava competindo s seu s
sua s estágio e roni o sul porque chegou
a esse projeto
e acrescentou que o evento o prefeito
mirim da escola da prova o que aconteceu
como eu sou bastante uma verdadeira
transformação que a partir do momento em
que esse produto está acontecendo o
processo dele e que ele seria o
responsável por apresentar os seus
colegas de escola e se tornou um top e
pacificação ele daquela colectividade
alguns vereadores vão principal
com isso os seus amigos conseguiu coisas
extraordinárias conseguir um espaço na
câmara depois da cidade uma peça
doméstica e lá repubblica as
necessidades de apoio da escola
conseguiram serem convidados a compor
conferências escolas municipais foi
discutido em todo o sítio onde se o
conseguir uma audiência com o vice no
crato passar e com a reivindicar a
reforma muito competitiva da escola
e uma vez que há 15 respectiva contribui
e há como muito se deve ao forte um
conjunto sobre a profecia se transformar
em outra pessoa e dependente de
matemática passou para premiar as
olimpíadas brasileiras ano
tinha um que não tinha perspectiva de
futuro hoje é uma pessoa que você
conversa com uma clareza de carreira
entanto é dele que é interessante é uma
onde se sente bem quem é e se sente bem
quando ele faz e é esse powers haw todos
os seus colegas todos aqueles naquela
não deve ter uma professora usou que
romário é uma determinada peça inclusive
provavelmente perder principalmente por
ex gestores
muitas pessoas perderam que estava a
sair e algo único problema da
experiência do romeno foi da professora
eliana é que a situação lá em santarém
no pará
mas o problema é que eles têm lá e o
problema é que eu sou é é todo mundo que
enfrentava a gente vê quase todas as
cidades de baton principal da ira de
alguns em perspectiva que nós com uma
passada falou pra gente 77 anos é
competitivo
obcecado com essa questão e com esse
desafio que os lobos poetas assumir é o
propósito de 5v nova plataforma
uma política que pretende se que a onu
do brasil inteiro pudesse ter uma
experiência muito parecida com uma turma
nisso ea professora tiveram essa forma
hoje o que se chama no activo ea nossa
fé essa plataforma a partir dessas
muitas experiências como adiantamento
paulo e se preparar o principal filósofo
companheiros do rio a professora eliana
vai tentar aproveitar a tecnologia
permitir de escolas professores é uma
das 30 poços enganamos a escola prática
de mudança nas suas comunidades locais
aproveitar o sol se na bola
ingredientes novos faz com o objetivo
dessa nossa senhora história professor
de língua gestual porque mostra que em
política não é só aquela coisa chata de
pessoas ligarem gravatá é só aquela
coisa repugnante e já tivemos total
testamos uma opção que política se faz
com o objetivo de que é possível se
transformar a nossa receita não é uma
receita para o aprendizado na partida
que passa assim a nossa receita é um
conjunto de tecnologias e um conjunto de
perspectivas para que são uma paixão
acontece de problema deles possam
identificar possíveis soluções e
articular apoios locais a convenção só
esse poder a arte
as receitas essa é uma plataforma que
tem como objetivo não deixou nenhuma
sentava à mesa de jantar e esperando
receber a sua intenção
como hoje é igual e faz o aluno sentado
na cadeira e e produzir o mesmo modelo
de uso real 7 50 anos atrás que só
aceita mas colocaria tentar presídio
local dentro da cozinha que deixou ontem
a competência é uma potência em camaçari
isso aconteça informações cada peixe
fire no brasil
alguns inclusive de preto divide o caixa
é condições econômicas muito machucado
não tendo assim acesso à internet
assim acesso às máquinas não tendo assim
acesso precipitação que superar isso ela
colocasse a bola
a condição de alguém que não sabe
cozinhar é diferente de mim
muitas vezes não sabem por que é que
querem começar a fazer uma educação mais
próxima e mais o futuro essa plataforma
visa conectar ao longo do sul diferentes
cozinhas diferentes lugares do brasil
para que possam se engajar avançar sua
obra tinha que entender é bom que em
diferentes contextos diferentes pessoas
os mesmos problemas que estão
conseguindo resolver de forma diferente
porque isso é a sociedade religião
sociedade que constrói o conhecimento a
partir da copa e esse é o fugitivo essa
nossa ideia é essa nossa proposta de
transformação muito orgulho hoje afirma
que estamos é um processo que é
excelente e aplicações patologias
problema é a umidade já viveu qualquer
para pegar algumas antes país e não
acredito em casa mas a minha falta uma
mulher aqui muito mais me explicar a
metodologia se for falar o motivo
especial é falar pra vocês prazer que me
chamar pra essa função diferente que a
gente comece o mais novo de forma
diferente e colocar dentro dessa nação
inclusive porque é a ação começa a
reconhecer que nós muita coisa não temos
as respostas com todos os problemas e
tal anos 61 pedir diferente tem uma
necessidade profissional frente a gente
não sai porque desconfiou aos mesmos 17
para us tão diferente com sonhos
quanto à diferença mas continuaram a
última antes de passar à nossa missão de
educar e é conhecido o mundo que todos
ou então a parte da série com a gente
que a gente enfrenta dificuldades porque
é assim que a gente vai construir um
brasil de utinga legal